la capitale russe qui face à la baisse
du nombre de contaminations de kovy 19
alléger ces restrictions sanitaires bars
restaurants et boîtes de nuit peut
désormais rester ouverts après 23 heures
reportage de vera goffman les
températures - 0 la neige le verglas ce
ne sont pas des raisons pour les
moscovites de rester à la maison ce
vendredi soir surtout s'ils saluent dans
le premier vendredi
depuis deux mois de levée d'interdiction
pour les restaurants et les boîtes de
nuit de travail et après 23 heures
honnêtement nous sommes vraiment heureux
que la quarantaine était élevé parce que
les jeunes ont vraiment besoin de sortir
le fait que des établissements qui
travaillent pour nous nous accueille
avec leurs portes ouvertes est
évidemment très positif
il ne peut en être autrement qui est
habitué c'est moscou une mégapole et ici
tout va fonctionner pour le client nous
souhaitons à tous une bonne santé et que
personne ne tombe malade
nous espérons tous que la pandémie nous
quittera bientôt et que nous
n'oublierons tous comme un mauvais rêve
l'assouplissement des restrictions entre
en vigueur après une amélioration stable
de la situation épidémiologique
le nombre de nouveaux malades ne dépasse
pas 2 3 milles par jour depuis une
semaine c'est encore pour cent des lits
dédiés aux malades de coronavirus sont
libres ou la première fois depuis
juillet on l'attendait avec impatience
c'est une nouvelle très importante et
grandiose pour nous si on revient disons
en mars 2020 cette période a bien sûr
été très difficile pour nous
moscou est une ville nocturne en général
il est donc très difficile d'imaginer
moscou sans cette vie de nuit moi je
suis pour le retour à notre ancienne vie
avant la pandémie le printemps et l'été
arrive notre belle véranda sera ouverte
je suis donc absolument pour le retour à
l'ancienne vie c'est avec espoir pour
ainsi dire que je regarde l'avenir
oui elle le coronavirus sur les pas
encore rompu mais l'on peut déjà
affrontées à la fin de la pandémie au
moins un bon coup